et si les gouvernements les médias et
les stars étaient de mèche derrière un
réseau mondial de pédophiles satanistes
qui opèrent en cachette un trafic sexuel
d'enfants et les sacrifices sur la
planète mars pour rester jeune
éternellement kamoulox non pardon au
complot
[Musique]
oula ça va pas être facile en ce coup là
non parce que c'est bien mignon de
croire à la terre plate ou ses lunettes
y aurait petit lien mais est-ce que vous
avez essayé de combiner toutes les
théories du complot qui existe c'est un
peu le boss final du game plus fort que
les scénaristes de south park j'ai nommé
qui nous étonne pour commencer je vais
vous raconter une petite histoire celle
du pizza gates nous sommes en 2016 en
pleine campagne présidentielle pour
savoir qui gouvernera des états unis
d'amérique entre hillary clinton et
donald trump spoiler quand soudain fuite
tout un tas de mails d'hillary clinton
et ses proches notamment le chef de son
cabinet et non pas de ses qualités c'est
là qu'on découvre qu'il a envoyé
plusieurs mails au propriétaire d'une
pizzeria qui est aussi un grand
financeurs de la campagne de clinton
dans lesquelles ils parlent de pizza au
fromage les internautes ne se font pas
berné ils comprennent tout de suite que
c'est un code pour pornographie
enfantine le chef de cabinet sera
impliqué dans un réseau d' esclavage
sexuel d'enfants et les clinton avec lui
un homme convaincu de cette théorie va
même jusqu'à attaqué au fusil d'assaut
la pizzeria en voulant libérer les
enfants emprisonnés dans la cave
surprise et pas d'enfant ça ne va pas
pour autant découragé les complotistes
c'est juste que cette conspiration est
beaucoup mieux cacher qu'il ne s'y
attendent donc beaucoup plus vaste vous
pourrez voir dans cet incident les
prémices de quynh anh tuân anh c'est un
mouvement complotistes américain plutôt
d'extrême droite qui est véritablement
né en 2017 un an plus tard sur le forum
anonyme forte chan tout est parti d'un
message posté par un mystérieux q je
rassure il écrivait probablement plus
tôt avec ses bois enfin j'espère voici
ce message hrc extradition déjà en cours
depuis hier avec plusieurs pays en cas
de fuite à la frontière bla bla bla pour
preuve si vous voyez un membre de la
police demandez lui si activé pour de
voir le 30 novembre dans la plupart des
grandes villes en gros si j'ai bien
compris il annonce ici l'arrestation
imminente d'hillary clinton en tant
qu'actrice non pas dans une pub pour du
dentifrice mais dans un complot mondial
pédophiles sata liste divulguée à charge
elle est toujours en liberté le pseudo
de ce cube revoir un niveau
d'habilitation très haut dans
l'administration américaine en gros ce
sera un haut fonctionnaire qui sait des
trucs top secret et qui les balances sur
un forum où se côtoient des mêmes et des
contenus pornographiques voire
pédopornographiques par jour assure les
messages de kew seront toujours cryptic
parlant code est posé question du genre
de qui des contrôles et si à vous de
trouver les réponses par vous même c'est
un peu un père fouras 2.0 et donc les
partisans de kew ceux qui croient au
bien-fondé de ces messages sont appelés
les tubes i'm not your anonyme leur
passion repérer le mot autre petit
détail et une couleur de cravate un
signe de la main et y voir des indices
en faveur de cette cabale planète rouge
le lieutenant columbo n'a qu'à bien se
tenir oui mais référence date un peu
mais je me souviens que voulez vous
hilary ne serait pas la seule visée dans
cette terrible conspiration mondiale
sera impliqué d'autres politiciens du
parti démocrate comme barack obama des
stars d'hollywood ou des milliardaires
comme la famille rothschild et
évidemment les médias sont complices
aussi sauf fox news dans ceux là ça va
inutile de vous dire qui a jamais eu
aucune preuve pour étayer cette
hypothèse un tout petit peu farfelue il
n'empêche qu'au tour de ces quelques
messages de kew va se monter tout un
mouvement complotistes voir un petit peu
sectaire sur les bords pardon dit
religieux je crois avec un messi qui
oeuvrent en cachette contre l'apocalypse
et pour démanteler ce réseau sata nos
pédophiles vivi n'en par donald trump il
est vu comme le sauveur qui doit mener
ce combat épique mondial contre le mal
absolu ça ferait un super film ça
dommage qu hollywood soit de mèche avec
les conspirateurs alors bien sûr trump
n'a jamais rien confirmé mais il est
malin il a rien de sûr mais non plus
c'est une partie de ses électeurs qui
lui voue un culte ça serait dommage de
se tirer une balle dans play comme une
interview quand on lui demande ce qu'ils
pensent dès qu un homme il répond oh
vous savez je ne sais pas grand chose
mais j'ai cru comprendre que ce sont des
personnes qui aiment leur pays et à qui
trouve que je suis quelqu'un de bien il
réussir tout est au moins 300 fois des
membres qui avec ses quelque 80 millions
d'abonnés selon a fait une sacrée pub
cette mouvance complot religieuse aurait
pris énormément d'ampleur depuis 2010
cette grâce au pouvoir des réseaux
sociaux et notamment des youtuber
complotistes les tubes heures et des
install rameuses les pastels kuen près
d'un électeur américain sur quatre
serait que wayne et on en compterait
plus de 80 sur les 535 membres du
congrès est l'équivalent de nos sénat et
assemblée nationale bon si c'était
uniquement des fêtes new passe encore
vous avez bien droit de croire qu'une
cabale pédo satanique se trame sous nos
yeux après tout certains croient bien
que le beurre doux c'est délicieux goût
si ça leur fait plaisir sauf que là le
vieil a qualifié qu il nomme de
mouvements représentant un risque
terroriste des gens sont morts en 2019
un tireur se revendiquant de kubina a
abattu un homme qu'il soupçonnait de
participer au complot en 2020 une femme
a été arrêtée dans sa voiture en
possession de 18 couteau s'était pas une
cuisinière qui s'apprêtait à participer
à top chef mais bien une qu un homme qui
se rendait à washington pour tuer joe
biden qui était candidat à la
présidentielle face à trump et vous vous
souvenez peut-être de l'attak du
capitole le 6 janvier 2020 terme à
d'ailleurs fait une vidéo là dessus
parmi les émeutes y figurait une bonne
brouettée de kurion cinq personnes sont
mortes lors de cet assaut cette
tentative de coup d'état c'est du jamais
vu aux états unis donc non seulement le
mouvement qu 'on a fait des morts et est
considéré comme un risque d'avoir east
mais en plus il a contribué à mettre en
péril démocratie américaine face à cette
montée de la violence et de la
désinformation you are fighting twitter
et facebook ont supprimé à l'appel des
comptes qui honore et aussi le compte
twitter de donald trump ou petits mais
c'est sans doute parce qu'il détient la
vérité est qu'on cherche à le faire
taire bon vous dit peut-être que tout ça
finalement c'est les américains qui se
comporte comme tel un lundi comme un
autre etats unis croient mais si tu veux
vous que ces croyances se sont même
exporté jusqu en europe l'allemagne et
le royaume-uni en tête il ya une petite
communauté francophone aussi et d'après
une enquête de l'institut pour le
dialogue stratégique à l'été 2020 il y
aurait quatre cent cinquante mille
aficionados du mouvement qu iron en
europe comme on m'a dit tout au début
être qu un jeune ce n'est pas uniquement
croire en une conspiration cet anneau
pédophiles mondiale qui va même jusqu'à
affirmer que la nasa aurait kidnappé des
enfants pour établir une colonie
d'esclaves sur mars et leur pomper le
sang lors d'un rituel satanique
cannibale pour y prélever une molécule
miracle l'adreno chrome qui sera à la
fois une puissante drogue et un élixir
de jouvence pensez-y si vous avez des
enfants un jour toujours privilégié le
circuit court bon prenons quand même une
petite minute pour cette histoire d'à
dreno chrome cette molécule existe bien
c'est un dérivé de l'adrénaline une arme
and cons ces crêtes quand on est stressé
ou fatigués d'une on peut la fabriquer
en laboratoire donc pas besoin d'ouvrir
des enfants 2 pour l'obtenir et puis
pourquoi des enfants et 2 2 ce n'est
absolument pas une drogue certains ont
essayé de ce linge était de la sniffer
de la vallée de la fumée et ça leur a
fait rien du tout ou très peu quelques
maux de tête quoi en fait cette théorie
complètement fumeuse viendrait d'un film
las vegas parano dans lequel l'un des
personnages se drogue à l'aide raynaud
chrome dans le livre dont est tiré le
film les personnages obtiennent la
substance des mains d'un satanistes vous
arrêter pour avoir abusé d'enfants dont
complotistes ont pas été chercher bien
loin mais du coup c'est une fiction n'y
a rien de réel et par ailleurs si c'est
un élixir de jouvence et bar est trop
bien j'en veux en passant ya rien
d'humain sur mars non plus injuste des
robots qui grattent le sol et prennent
des selvi bon ça c'est fait donc non
cette mouvance ne se contente pas de
cette conspirateurs nos draps culot
pédophiles les kiwis jeunes sont aussi
anti masque anti vaccin anti 5g
anti-avortement antilopes antigel
antibiotiques antillais anti mutant
tittley nos antiques al antidiarrhéiques
pardon je me suis
c'est la magie de k'naan c'est un menu
complotistes vous choisissez vos
croyances à la carte et la période de
crise sanitaire duo kobe 19 n'a rien
arrangé on ya vu une montée très
important des théories complotistes
partout dans le monde les principaux
contributeurs aux nonnes aurait
multiplié par sept le nombre de leurs
membres dans les quatre premiers mois de
la pandémie aux états unis et dans le
monde francophone on a eu un hold up le
documenteur complotistes qui
interviewent une quinzaine parmi son lot
et d'export et dont le réalisateur
conclu par face à la grande
réinitialisation qui va soumettre les
peuples du monde entier il y aurait donc
le président trump comme ultime recours
face à une élite mondialistes savoir
avait pas un truc au résumé ils sont
anti tout et ils sont partout jusqu'au
congrès américain et ils fomentent au
sein de leur propre sphère sur internet
et si c'était eux le complot les queen
anne qui les contrôlent
j'ai pas pourquoi je fais
[Musique]